وهنا الحدود والمعترف بها من قبل المجتمع
الدولي
هذا الاجتماع في مدينه السلام مدينه منستر
كان خيارا متعمدا من قبل في كل يوم منذ
254 رئاسه الماني لمجموعه السبعه حاربنا
من اجل نهايه هذه الحرب والاستعاده السلام
الى اوروبا وبالتالي
اه في ايه
على معالجه العواقبه المريعه التي سبت
بهذه الحرب عندما ننظر الاشهر الماضيه
ندرك بان مجموعه السبعه
[موسيقى]
شهد عشره اجتماعات الوزراء الخارج
منذ البدايه على تنسيق
الجهودي الاكبر احد ممكن مساعده الاوكراني
لا اقصى حد في حربهم من اجل البقاء نعم
يحق القول بان العديد من المهام الاخرى
عامل ايه
لقد
وفرنا الملايين من المساعدات الى
الانسانيه والدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا
ولكن يجب ان نتخذ القرارات السياسيه يوما
بعد الاخر
طويل
في كل يوم يجب ان نقرر الى جانب من نقف
الى جانب المعتدي الى جانب
الضحيهن الذي حاول فيه النظام الروسي
من خلالها في الظلام ومن دون اي تدفئه
فنحن الى جانبي الاوكرانيين في كل يوم
امها طال الامد وفي كل يوم مهما كانت
الصعوبه
زميلي الاوكراني اصبح صديقا مقربا كان
واضحا جدا في كلماته يوم امس حول ما
يحتاجه الاوكرانيون هذه الايام ولهذا
السبب فقد جمعنا حزما من اجل فتره الشتاء
ثم ولد
سبعه نحن
فحسبنا فعلنا اكثر من ذلك فقد وافقنا على
اليوم والغرض منها
كشطات سنس اللي عايز سونج
على كيف يمكن ان يوفر افضل ان الدعم ونكمل
جهود بعضنا البعض ما فعلناه خلال الشهرين
الماضيين لاكمال جهود بعضنا البعض امام
عندما تحدثوا عن ايصال القمح والاسلحه
وتوفير المساعدات الانسانيه هذه من
الاشياء تاثير سنستمر بها خاصه خلال فتره
الشتاء ليس فقط اعضاء مجموعه السبعه بلا
اعضاء المجتمع الدولي ايضا اماني الشعب
الاوكراني يحصل على ما يحتاج اليه لكي
يتمكن من تجاوز فتره الشتاء القادمه
وتجاوز فيها
بالاجماع على اننا
نقبل وبدون اي شروط عندما تهاجم
الديمقراطيه يجيبوا سوف نساهم بكل ما
لدينا ونحارب من اجل
تثبيته
على انها ناهد اقتصادي حتى اليوم نحن
يمثلوا اكثر من 40% منها الاجمالي العالمي
ولكن اكثر من اي وقت سبق علينا ان نذكر
انفسنا بحقيقه ان الامر لا يجرؤ فقط حول
الازدهار الاقتصادي
وازدهارنا او خلال الثراء الذي جمعناه
ياتي بثمن ولا يمكن ان
نفخر بالكامل بكل ثروات التي جمعناها
بالتالي فان مسؤوليتنا الان هي الاصغاء
وان نساهم بكل
المشاكل العالم
ابرز ما قالته ان المجموعه